Transcriber: Youstina Yousrii
المدقّق: Mujtaba bakhet
أهلاً وسهلاً بكم جميعًا.
في يوم الثلاثاء 24 أكتوبر 2017.
كنت جالسًا في إحدى غرف الدراسة.
لمركز “هيلي فاميلي الطلابي“:
“هيلي فاميلي ستور أن سنتر“.
في جامعتي الرائعة:
“جامعة جورج تاون“.
في العاصمة الأمريكية “واشنطن دي سي“.
تقع “واشنطن” في الضفة الشمالية
الشرقية لنهر “بوتوماك“.
وهذا هو موقعها الجغرافي.
ولكنها تقع أيضًا في القلب
من الدهاليز السياسية.
وقصص التنافس والطموح المتشابكة.
التي ربما ألهمت صانعي المسلسل
الشهير “هاوس أوف كاردز“.
لإنتاج دراما التشويق السياسية
التي طارت في الأفاق.
كنت أنذاك في سنتي الثامنة
في “الولايات المتحدة“،
وفي السنة الرابعة لبرنامج الدكتوراه،
في الدراسات العربية والإسلامية
في جامعة “جورج تاون“.
وكان “هيلي فاميلي” مقصدًا دائمًا لي،
ولكثيرين من أعضاء مجتمع “جورج تاون“.
الذين كانوا يذهبون إلى هناك للبحث
والقراءة والكتابة والاطلاع.
أو حتى لاستغلال الشاشات
الضخمة في هذا المركز.
لمتابعة الجديد في الرياضة أو السياسة.
أيضًا كانت تدور الكثير من النقاشات هناك.
خصوصًا حول حالة الحروب الثقافية.
التي بدأ يزداد اشتعالها في
“الولايات المتحدة” منذ ذلك الوقت.
وبالطبع النقاشات في مدينة
مثل “واشنطن دي سي“،
غالبا ما تكون نقاشات ساخنة جدًا.
فهذه مدينة تقع على مفترق الطرق.
بين الإعلام والسياسة.
بين الأكاديمية،
و“الثينك تانكس” أو مراكز الفكر.
وبين الدبلوماسية والمراكز
الثقافية والفنية العالمية.
ولكن في ذلك اليوم.
24 أكتوبر 2017،
لم تكن لتلفت انتباهي تلك الشاشات الضخمة
في “هيلي فاميلي ستور أن سنتر“.
ولم أكن لأهتم بالحالة الأمريكية بأكملها.
فقد كانت عيناي مسمرتين،
على شاشة صغيرة لجهاز “ماك بوك” الخاص بي.
بينما كانت أذناي...
تنصتان بمزيج من الإعجاب والدهشة والانبهار.
إلى كلمات تعلن للعالم،
عن إطلاق المشروع السعودي
الطموح وغير المسبوق.
الذي أطلق عليه اسم “نيوم“.
كل ما في إعلان “نيوم”
كان مدهشًا وجذابًا ومميزًا.
ولكن ربما لكوني كائنًا لغويًا
بالدرجة الأولى.
بدأت أركز أكثر في اسم المشروع.
فهذا الاسم يتكون من جزئين:
“نيو“.
وترمز إلى كلمة جديد في اللغة الإغريقية
وبعض اللغات الغربية اليوم.
والجزء الثاني وهو حرف “الميم“.
والذي يرمز إلى كلمة “مستقبل”
باللغة العربية.
فبالتالي كانت “نيوم”
هي “المستقبل الجديد“.
بهذا يتجاوز الاسم في خصائصه اللغوية،
أو هكذا قرأته،
ثنائية الشرق والغرب.
ليكون الاسم الأنسب لهذا المشروع الطموح.
الذي يعد بحقبة حضارية جديدة.
يمكن للناس من مختلف التنوعات الثقافية،
أن يبنوا فيها عالمًا مشتركًا.
ينعم بالسلام والازدهار والثراء الثقافي.
في قلب الجزيرة العربية.
كنت أتابع إعلان “نيوم“،
وكان حولي طالبات وطلاب “جورج تاون“،
وهم يأتون من تنوعات ثقافية هائلة.
فبدا لأن هناك رابطًا بين هذا التنوع
والتنوع الذي تعد به “نيوم“.
ولكن من جانب أخر، ولكون بعض
هؤلاء الطلاب كنت قد التقيتهم بالفعل،
في صف دراسي أو أكثر،
من صفوف الثقافة العربية،
التي حظيت بفرصة تدريسها
في “جورج تاون” منذ عام 2014.
لم يكن بوسعي حقيقة إلا أن
أتذكر بعضًا من الأسئلة المتكررة...
لهؤلاء الطلاب الأذكياء حول بلادي.
هؤلاء الطلاب يأتون من تخصصات
العلاقات الدولية والسياسات الخارجية.
وبعضهم يتخصص في الدراسات العربية
والإسلامية ودراسات الشرق الأوسط.
ومع ذلك، كنت أفاجأ بأسئلة من قبيل:
“هل يُسمح بتداول كتب الفلسفة،
والأدب الحديث لديكم في السعودية؟”
“هل هناك فن سعودي حديث ومعاصر؟”
“هل هناك مفكرون سعوديون؟”
“كيف استطعت أن تكتب رسالة الماجستير
عن شاعر مثل المتنبي،
بينما شعره لا يتفق مع النظام
الأخلاقي لديكم في السعودية؟”
وبالتأكيد، معظم هذه الأسئلة كانت تدور
حول الموضوع المفضل لدى كثيرين.
وهو موضوع المرأة السعودية.
الذي لحسن الحظ كان قد خسر مؤخرًا
سؤال المليون دولار:
“لماذا لا تقود المرأة السعودية السيارة؟”
قد تبدو لنا هذه الأسئلة غريبة نوعًا ما،
كما أنها تخالف الواقع.
وهي بالتأكيد أسئلة لا تنتمي إلى المستقبل
الذي تعد به “نيوم“، و“رؤية السعودية 2030”.
ومع ذلك فهي أسئلة مفهومة تمامًا في سياقها.
فهناك صورة نمطية سطحية أو سردية “نيرتيف“،
اختزالية وتبسيطية وجوهرنية.
لثقافة الجزيرة العربية،
نتيجة لعوامل كثيرة جدًا، من أهمها:
غياب محتوى علمي رصين،
عن التداول الأكاديمي
في الأكاديمية الغربية.
عن ثقافة الجزيرة العربية والخليج والمملكة.
ومن هنا يتخرج بعض طلاب
هذه الأقسام المتخصصة.
وهم ينقصهم الكثير من المعرفة.
عن ثقافة هذا الجزء من العالم.
فيما بعد، بعض هؤلاء الخريجين
يتبوأون مناصب مهمة.
كمستشارين في سياسات الشرق الأوسط.
وتبقى تلك الصورة السطحية.
تتحرك في الخلفية لتؤثر
في كيفية النظر إلى دول المنطقة.
وفي كيفية صنع السياسات للتعامل معها.
ومن هنا يعُاد تدوير هذه الصورة السطحية.
وتتكرر المشكلة التي اشتكى منها
الأديب السعودي والدبلوماسي المعروف:
“غازي القصيبي“، حينما قال:
“نفطٌ، يقول الناس عن وطني.”
“ما أنصفوه، وطني هو المجد.”
في الحقيقة لطالما واجهت مشكلات
كتلك التي اشتكى منها “غازي القصيبي“.
منذ أن ذهبت إلى
“الولايات المتحدة” في عام 2010.
فتخصصي هو الدراسات الشرقية
والدراسات العربية والإسلامية.
وما يمكن تسميته بالسؤال السعودي.
هو جزء أساسي من النقاشات في هذه التخصصات.
وفي يوم إطلاق “نيوم” كنت أقول في نفسي:
“إنه لأمر يستحق التأمل،”
“أن نقارن بين هذه الصور النمطية السطحية،”
“وبين سردية المستقبل الجديد.”
“الذي تعد به ‘نيوم’.”
“والذي نراه يتخلق أمامنا يوميًا بفعل
المبادرات المتنوعة والثقافية تحديدًا.”
“ ‘لرؤية السعودية 2030’.”
“التي تبشر بمستقبل واعد للمنطقة.”
“وتحث على الاعتزاز بالهوية الثقافية
مع بناء جسور التواصل مع العالم.”
ومن هنا للإسهام في بناء هذه الجسور.
فقد حرصت، تحديدًا في “جورج تاون“،
على تقديم المواد الإبداعية لأبناء المنطقة
إلى المجتمع الأكاديمي هناك.
وسأضرب مثالًا واحدًا على ذلك.
ففي ربيع عام 2018،
حظيت بفرصة تدريس
مادة الأدب العربي الحديث هناك،
وانضم إليها طلاب بكالوريوس وماجستير
ودكتوراه من تخصصات متنوعة.
وكانت فرصة رائعة لتقديم
المواد الإبداعية لأبناء المنطقة.
لهؤلاء الطلاب.
ولاستضافة بعض هؤلاء المبدعين لدينا.
في هذا الصف الدراسي،
للحديث بشكل مباشر مع الطلاب.
كان هذا النقاش يزيد من مساحة المعرفة
بثقافة الجزيرة العربية.
ويؤدي إلى تكوين فهم أدق.
عن ثقافة هذا الجزء
الثري إبداعيًا من العالم.
الشهر الأخير من هذا الفصل الدراسي،
خصصته لواحد من أهم شعرائي المفضلين.
وهو الشاعر السعودي “محمد الثبيتي“.
وأعتقد أن تخصيص هذا الشهر “للثبيتي“،
هو نوع من أنواع التحيز الحميد.
الذي أُصبت به في ذلك الوقت.
قرأ الطلاب نصوص “الثبيتي” التأسيسية في
التضاريس و“موقف الرمال موقف الجناس“.
ولكم أن تتخيلوا أن طلابًا
يدرسون الأدب العربي لأول مرة.
حفظوا مقاطع من شعر “الثبيتي“.
وقرأوا بتعمق في الحالة
الثقافية السعودية بشكل عام.
وأذكر أننا في الأسبوع الأخير.
خرجنا إلى الساحة الخارجية
“لهيلي فاميلي ستور أن سنتر”.
التي تطل على نهر “بوتوماك” في “واشنطن”.
وطلب أحد الطلاب أن يلقي مقطعًا حفظه.
من قصيدة “موقف الرمال
موقف الجناس” “لمحمد الثبيتي“.
فقام يلقي أمامنا المقطع الشهير.
فقال: “يا أيها النخل،
يغتابك الشجر الهزيل.“
“ويذمك الوتد الذليل، وتظل تسمو،“
“في فضاء اللّه ذا ثمر خرافي وذا صبر جميل.“
في الحقيقة، لم يكن طلابي في “جورج تاون” هم
وحدهم من رأوا في ذلك المقطع أمرًا خاصًا.
فعلى مشارف نهاية هذا الصف الدراسي،
وتحديدًا في 3 مايو 2018.
نشر الحساب الرسمي لوزارة
الخارجية السعودية في “تويتر” تغريدة...
يشيد فيها “بمحمد الثبيتي” كأحد أبرز
أقطاب الحداثة الأدبية في العالم العربي.
وماذا كان المقطع الذي اختارته هذه الوزارة،
التي تتمثل مهمتها في بناء
جسور التواصل مع العالم؟
لم يكن إلا مقطع “النخل“، الذي يسمو...
في فضاء إلا ذا ثمر خرافي وذا صبر جميل.
قُبلت هذه التغريدة بحماس كبير جدًا،
وقرأها بعضهم،
كإشارة رمزية على التحول الثقافي
الهائل الذي تشهده المملكة.
بفعل مبادرات “رؤية السعودية 2030“.
ولم يطل الأمر حقيقة،
لكي ينتقل هذا التحول
من شكله الرمزي، في هذه التغريدة،
إلى الشكل المؤسساتي.
فبعد شهر واحد فقط من هذه التغريدة.
أُعلن عن إنشاء أول وزارة
متخصصة للثقافة في تاريخ البلاد.
وبعد ذلك بأشهر،
أُطلقت الاستراتيجية الوطنية للثقافة.
لتكون المحرك الذي يقود هذا التحول الثقافي.
نحو بيئة ثقافية تنبض بالحياة،
وتزدهر فيها الفنون،
وتربط الأمة السعودية الشابة،
بتقاليدها التراثية الغنية والعميقة.
حينها أيقنت بأن العالم سيشهد عما قريب.
حقبة جديدة من التنوير الثقافي.
تنطلق هذه المرة من قلب الجزيرة العربية.
حيث ولدت اللغة والثقافة العربية
والمعلقات العشر.
ونزل الوحي القرأني العربي
المبين منذ مئات السنين.
بعد ذلك بأشهر،
وُفقت لمناقشة رسالة الدكتوراه.
وكان الأدب السعودي جزءًا أساسيًا فيها.
ثم عدت إلى المملكة،
لأشهد بشكل مباشر هذا التحول الثقافي.
ومنذ عودتي حظيت بفرصة الاستمتاع.
بما يمكن أن تقدمه الثقافة السعودية
لمواطنيها وزائريها وللعالم أجمع.
وزاد يقيني بقدرة الأعمال
الإبداعية على بناء الجسور الثقافية.
فعبر تعزيز هذه الروابط بين الشرق والغرب.
تتخلق دائما فرص إبداعية جديدة،
وينشأ فهم عالمي أكثر دقة.
عن أمة سعودية حديثة.
جذورها التاريخية راسخة،
وثقافتها المعاصرة مزدهرة،
وبناتها وأبناؤها شركاء
في جعل العالم مكانًا أفضل.
وأخيرًا، اليوم بينما أتنقل في شوارع...
جدة والرياض والدمام والعلا،
وجازان والباحة وأبها وحائل والمدينة ومكة.
أتذكر ذلك المستقبل الذي...
وعد به إعلان إطلاق “نيوم“.
وأجد حولي لافتات الاحتفاء
بعام الشعر العربي.
وبالمهرجانات الثقافية المتنوعة.
فارفع بصري إلى السماء،
وأتذكر باندهاش قول “محمد الثبيتي“.
وهو يحتفي بتضاريس البلاد المتنوعة.
وبأولئك الناظرين إلى الأمام.
الناظرين إلى المستقبل، وهو يقول:
“ونظرت في عين السماء، فخبت شرارة الظماء”
“وانشق عن مطر غمام للبائتين على الطواء”
“والناشرين لمن طوى والناظرين إلى الأمام”
“للنخل، للكثبان، للشيح الشمالي”
“وللنفحات من ريح الصبا،
للطير في خضر الربى”
“للشمس للجبل الحجازي وللبحر التهامي.“
شكرا لكم.